[Musique]
c'est que tu sais qu du chili
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tétine dans les 24 boîtes qui sont
devant vous puis j'ai procédé à un
second tirage au sort et j'ai tous des
cons tants des boîtes mer cinéma trop
moyens aujourd'hui c'est la réouverture
des terrasses à des restaurants et bars
regardez ce que j'ai là regardez ce que
villa déchets emballages vous savez il
fallait manger la cha cha cha pak pour
mes amis sans pas dit si j'arrêtais
quelqu'un qui veut du champagne coulait
pas battus truc mais bon un petit truc
pour mes amis je pète gerica boire du
coca bien du tennessee mais parce que la
balle allait pas mal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle aura pu faire c'est d'être avec la
sécu c'est que du qui bien entendu une
émission d'information ce soir encore on
parlera de tout ce qui se passe dans
toute la france bien entendu on aura
l'analyse de nos différents ces
éditorialistes merci on est en partie
rom était la venue de ces partis bien
sûr bien sûr mais avec double
[Musique]
allez et moringue
non
c'est que du qui bien entendu une
émission d'information et on refera bien
sûr des happenings dans la rue moi j'ai
envie qu'on soit dans la rue tous les
jours dans la rue comme ça car la rue la
rue c'est mon rim
oui la russie gwoka il est 19 heures 4
pour l'instant je vous explique on peut
juste faire ça avec une caméra portable
c'est à dire il ya un cadreur et moi
j'ai un micro pour tout le monde
l'émission d'un travail ne peut pas la
diffusion qui toquent 9h26 on est en
direct les ferries le problème est
résolu on à résorber le problème
techniques inhérents à une inondation
bicéphale au niveau du sous-sol du
premier étage barbade
c'est que du qui bien entendu une
émission d'information
[Musique]